if you're one of the millions of people
who saw Avengers infinity war on opening
weekend chances are you've got some
questions about what you've just watched
and what's going to happen next but more
than anything you probably want to know
about that one moment no one saw coming
you know the one the good news is if
you're ready to dive into the
nitty-gritty of the movie and its many
connections to the comics there's no
reason to wait any longer let's get to
it do we even need to say spoilers ahead
let's go as we see an infinity war
Thanos forces Gamora to take him to the
soul stone after she's forced to reveal
its location on the planet Vermeer
they're the pair find that the keeper of
the stone is our old pal the Red Skull
who seemed to me this demise when he was
sucked into the tesseract itself aka the
space stone and then shot into outer
space in the first Captain America movie
he might look a little different when he
shows up an infinity war of course since
Hugo Weaving didn't return to play the
character and was instead portrayed by
The Walking Dead's Ross Marquand but
it's still definitely the skull so
what's he doing all the way out on
Vermeer Red Skull explains that he was
cast out by the space stone and
imprisoned on Vermeer doomed to lead
others to the soul stone without ever
being able to use it himself in the
comics of course red skulls relationship
with the Infinity stones isn't really a
thing but he does have a lot of history
with the Cosmic Cube an item with
similar powers to the MC use tesseract
however the Infinity stones are not
related to the comics Cosmic Cube say
that five times fast Red Skull is one of
Captain America's most frequent comic
book close and although the hero has
vanquished him time and time again he
uses the Cosmic Cube to come back from
the dead transform into and possess
people and travel through time but in
the MCU the space stone was his jam and
now we know that he isn't even connected
to that anymore now he just guards the
soul stone the only one of the six
Infinity stones that uses its owner
rather than letting its owner use it so
what's it all mean why would we see the
Red Skull in the scene at all well it
may be foreshadowing you know that there
are a lot of people who kick the bucket
in the end thanks to thanasis supreme
snap some of those people including
spider-man Doctor Strange and Black
Panther are expected to have more than
one stand-alone project on the MCU films
late so mourning those losses seems
premature to say the least
meanwhile the sole stone in the comics
tends to capture its wielder and contain
the souls of others within it in a place
called soul world so it's possible that
the red school wasn't trapped on war
mere to guard the stone instead he may
be one of the stones prisoners after all
the Red Skull has been there for decades
he should be dead but the soul stone has
kept him alive this whole time so maybe
some of the other characters who seemed
to die in infinity war have been kept
alive by the soul stone too
this could potentially answer the
question of how some of the many
superheroes who bit the dust in the film
could be brought back in time for the
4th movie could those who are snapped
out of existence all be residing in the
soul world now there are other ways the
4th Avengers film could bring back those
lost heroes of course especially since
the time stone was proven to be able to
do exactly that by Thanos himself but if
the Russo brothers are looking to
surprise some folks with a more
unexpected resurrection
well the red skulls guardianship of the
soul stone might have just laid the
groundwork for exactly that Wow thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]